sometimes watching a movie just won't do
you also want to eat that movie that's
why there's movie recipes today we're
gonna show you how to make an after
earth pizza there's a pizza that tastes
exactly like the movie after Earth okay
so the base of our after earth pizza is
not your traditional crust we're going
to use Will Smith
but not just any Will Smith you need to
tenderize that until all traces of the
actors wealth
humor and charm are completely erased if
you don't have a meat tenderizer look
around the garage you can use almost
anything now any good pizza needs sauce
just like any good movie needs a basic
plot for our purposes today you need to
find the absolute most generic pizza
sauce you can find for me that was
valued now smear that generic all over
your Will Smith crust we need a meat for
our pizza so we're gonna recommend
pepperoni because it's the single most
processed meat you can find it's been
processed then processed some more just
like the after earth script for our
cheese we're gonna use the most bland
boring cheese we can find value brand
again delivers and this time with a
product that isn't even technically
cheese perfect don't forget to add the
Earth this week secret ingredient just
go outside and grab a handful of dirt
put this on the grill for 10 to 12
minutes you'll know it's done when it's
burned and smelling plasticky finally
garnish with a lit cigarette and enjoy
mm Shyamalan
[Music]